les amateurs de la solanum tubéosome ne
manquerait pour rien au monde ce
rendez-vous de ce début d'automne à
Haute-Saône je veux parler de la foire à
la patate à la filature de Ronchamp 24e
du nom au programme des produits du
terroir des animations mais aussi et
surtout bien entendu des pommes de terre
en pagaille Frédéric buridant Antoine
Laroche
en brouette ou pas on vient faire ses
réserves de pommes de terre il est vrai
que le temps estival est trompeur mais
nous sommes bien en automne et la pomme
de terre a toujours son petit succès
l'idiot a fait le chemin depuis Belfort
pour faire ses provisions vous avez
ramené combien de kilos de patates là il
y a ma kilo là bon bonne route merci moi
je vais pas aller trop vite parce qu'il
y a des radars cela fait plus de 20 ans
que Ronchamp accueille cette foire à la
patate a rendez-vous très attendu en ce
début d'automne pour les vendeurs de
fruits et légumes fidèles au rendez-vous
les pommes de terre
dans les environs de 800 kg et puis donc
pour 13h le stock Patriot pratiquement
épuisé les pommes on a appris de
fontaine de kilos il en reste tout de
même un peu au fourneau et pour
organiser 8 associations de Ronchin une
soixantaine de bénévoles qui continuent
à faire vivre cette tradition de la
pomme de terre dans un département
familièrement appelé la haute patate un
clin d'œil à la richesse agricole de la
Haute-Saône qu'à ce stand le féculent
est transformé en râpé de pommes de
terre alors un bout râpé il faut être
bien équipé d'une d'une bonne rappeuse
surtout de la main d'oeuvre de la bonne
humeur on a fait je sais pas moi combien
de kilos
150 kg la file d'attente est longue pour
profiter de la reine du jour et on vient
de loin pour la goûter cette galette
Lydia a pris la route depuis metabi et
pour l'occasion
ça me rappelle les beignets que ma
grand-mère faisait il
[Musique]
y a qu'à les manger à nouveau le
ravitaillement est fait prêt pour
l'automne et l'hiver en attendant la
prochaine édition en 2024